snowboard bonne année à toi et joyeux
Noël
un entretien téléphonique avec un jeune
garçon et sa famille à la veille du Noël
orthodoxe Vladimir Poutine affiche un
air beaucoup moins martial que ces
derniers mois le Kremlin annonce même un
c'est le feu sur le front ukrainien à
l'occasion de ce jour 5 compte tenu de
l'appel de Sa Sainteté le patriarche
Kyril j'instruis le ministre de la
Défense russe d'introduire un régime de
cessez-le-feu sur toute la ligne de
contact entre les parties en Ukraine à
partir de midi le 6 janvier de cette
année jusqu'à minuit le 7 janvier 36
heures de trêve qui interviendrait donc
à la demande du patriarche de l'Église
orthodoxe et que les autorités
ukrainiennes qualifient d'hypocrisie
même son de cloche du côté du président
américain
je suis plutôt réticent à commenter ce
que dit Poutine je pense qu'il cherche à
se redonner de l'air
pour Moscou cette pause pourrait en
effet servir à faire souffler ses
troupes et son opinion publique très
éprouvé après la frappe qui a tué des
dizaines de soldats russes le jour de
l'an à macifica le leader séparatiste
prorus de cette région de denietzk dans
l'est de l'Ukraine c'est lui rendu au
chevet des blessés et a tenté de
regalbaniser les troupes
je tiens à vous exprimer mon profond
respect nous nous dirigeons vers la
victoire maintenant vous allez vous
reposer et ensuite il sera temps de
prendre votre revanche
autre indice d'une volonté russe de
temporiser le communiqué relatant
l'entretien de jeudi matin entre
Vladimir Poutine et son homologue turcre
etchep tiper Doan affirme que la Russie
est prête à un dialogue sérieux avec
l'Ukraine à condition que celle-ci
accepte les nouvelles réalités
territoriales une condition
immédiatement rejetée par Kiev